nachos n
nachos my guy out of everything you said
nachos
Jes baby let me get your chicken
[Applause]
nuget what is he do like
I'm kle okay Amir are you two attracted
to each other yeah she's hot yeah
really objectively at least in my
opinion
so this is the real rist test did he say
he's a foreign baby cuz he has an
English accent queen's English hits
different yeah it does yeah yeah nobody
want that Biden English they want that
Queen English king now but whatever
King now yeah yeah nobody respect it was
it Charles it's the queen Charles
Charles keep doing your thing if you're
watching he hasn't done anything how do
you
know are you keeping tabs on what the
lizard men are
doing I didn't know you were part of
conspiracy watch you you went straight
to lizard Hey listen do you think the
queen really died you she just shed and
now she
TOS I pay attention
bro yeah y'all got astrology I got
conspiracies [__]
that's good yeah you got you got your
stars good it's the same
thing got lizard skin no but that's good
astrology is conspiracy of the Stars
yeah that's what I'm going start doing
yo anytime girl be like hey Sagittarius
I'm
like what I do is for the money yeah I
ain't I got you [__] walking around
and fear cuz I'm here I made that clear
I got different abilities I can taunt
you in filies working responsibilities
I'll make you disappear I'll stop right
there
I thought she was about to go like my
[__] paint my bully all round that [__]
but she more
conscious then you rappers man I can't
with them I women we rapping about the
coochie kill me bro why don't you two
take some time and talk about your
dating deal breakers oh I guess people
that aren't curious like if you're just
like happy in a cocoon you said happy
and can cook no in a cocoon like if it
just happen like your own Echo chamers I
your accent is so cute your cocoon when
women hear an accent on a dude it's like
dude staring at a woman's tits like they
stop listening to what you say and it's
about the package yeah I'm feeling a
connection
here I Love It Go red one more time if
you're feeling the connection as well
don't press
me I'm not a gambler I'm good you're not
a gambler I'm
good so I'm
personally do your
okay I did not
say damn that she was like only because
I'm a gambler but I do want to talk to
you again you're fine nah nah n n n no
no you can't just hand me a big old L
like that and be like left the chat
again unless it's you saying hi to my
[__] foot you I don't want to hear
nothing come out your mouth yeah toes
straight in there try talking with a
mouthful
I wear foot plops in the summer pause
yeah my toes stay ready you won't
[__] suck your toes yeah if
they handed me an L they need to get one
too cuz my toes are definitely enough
them toes need some
sucking what made you want to
gamble cuz I get bored fast I just like
such a dating red flag I don't know why
that is what what what is I get bored
really fast it's like what do you
[__] think a relationship is
full-time excitement
[__]
no m s was just a bit of resentment but
like every time I hear that of a girl
I'm just like yo then go take a trip you
know I mean like I ain't that dude and I
don't know who is you you want to
dateing James Bond or some [__] talking
about I get bored really fast watch some
Netflix why got to hop on
another am I crazy like even if a dude
said that to her like I get bored really
fast okay I'm not doing threesome what
do you want
stupid go play video games why you mean
like your partner doesn't have to be
your source of excitement it's just not
going to be you that's it probably not
going to be anyone else either until you
get through that face you're you're
going to be unbored and lonely look at
your hair can I see your nails though I
like a fashionation with like nails and
stuff really I yeah like I always
appreciate why someone shouldn't date
you I've actually never been in a
relationship really Shocker the girl who
gets bored easily exactly can't handle a
relationship
hello Hi how are you how are you nice to
meet you I'm good I'm sorry no no but it
was great to meet you how are you good
good what do you do like outside of work
and and whatnot I like to work out I
like to travel I really want to go to
like Cabo yo we can go
together the look was great I really
want kids yeah we can make babies
together absolutely yeah and maybe maybe
when someone's telling you their
aspirations you don't just insert
yourself in the first 2 seconds of
meeting them I don't know yo we can go
together all right I'm sorry I'm Mariah
nice to meet you I'm Zu Zu Y what are
you two looking for in a relationship
want to go first why are they doing
backtack tech support that's crazy
bro n that's crazy
bro n no n like this guy's at a higher
tier of tech support too yes I'm looking
for someone loyal compassionate driven
what about you yeah I I'm just curious
about you so that I mean I have like my
own goals I have like my own goals I'm
not looking for like anything terribly
like serious right now I mean I think
you know I'm open to the idea of you
know Finding like my wife one day but
you know it's not always possible at
least with my age I'm 22 how old are you
I'm 24 24 okay yeah so I'm definitely
older turned 23 in like two weeks
so he tried to pull that math out he
said listen hey Chad GPT how do I fix
this I took 23 2 weeks GP that's what he
sound like how do I fix he sound like he
get his dating advice from Chad GPT I'm
not going to lie I'm okay young guys I'm
going to give you guys a piece of advice
go ahead bro you're young shut the [__]
up about your
a if she that ass you don't say nothing
okay let me tell you
why cuz as a young man you're almost
like a Jehovah's Witness you got a
chance to speak to people until they
find out you're a Jehovah's Witness and
then they shutting that door so if you
want to be an effect of Jehovah's
Witness shut don't don't make it too
obvious just start talking make them
like you and then all of a sudden spring
it on them like you need salvation baby
like oh you didn't go through the steps
and if you're lucky by the time she asks
you you've already buil up enough
Rapport where you can she can Overlook
it but once you say it it just dies so
you have to make sure you do enough to
be able to bypass and I speak as a young
man who's been with other women much
older than me that was like the one
thing that would say okay just hey build
a conversation if they don't ask yeah
this guy volunteered like hey this is
why you should reject him he volunteered
I'm he too like like Uncle Samy is
looking for you he didn't say he didn't
show up hopefully that's not like a red
flag for you
um no
[Applause]
sorry what is she do
like Abba decided to get me you know he
wanted me to get enough upgrade so he
got me the parliament it's kind of nice
I got to admit but one thing I noticed
on the wallet is that ABBA wrote his
name on it his gift to me is me thinking
about
him
y yes I did that and I don't even regret
it you think I'm out here just giving
gifts to people so they can go off later
on and pretend like I didn't give it to
them you think I'm going really do that
do I look like a new fool I gave it to
you but you better remember it yeah
that's how I do my gifts with a string
attached today's video is brought to you
by extra listen one of my favorite
companies okay I partner for these guys
on the cheap cuz I [__] love what
they make these you guys saw the
previous one I gifted it to a bunch of
the homies every single one of them
still use it and loves using
them
listen I be on dates and when it's time
to pay for the bill I be
like
sh yay feel like James Bond in this
[__] okay love this you can hold up to
14 cards total if you want to use a
strap on the inside uh great fabric it
feels solid I've never had issues on the
inside I actually don't put extra cards
I put an air tag right here why think
about this cuz let's say you're in Miami
and then you lose your wallet when
you're with a sugar baby I lost my
wallet twice just popped it on my phone
bam okay this has been a lifesaver I've
saved so much I've already paid for the
wallet itself just by having the
tracking device on it if you want to up
your game go to the link in the
description below use code Abba and
preach and get 55% off
55 how you press me
let's wait till he
leaves the physical aspect I prefer like
African Aman she's black guys of course
she like you can tell like you can
tell basically he said yo she look
ratchet nice to meet you I got a
question for you um would you ever like
Skydive or anything like that that was a
dream of mine really you talking about a
dream of M know you I haven't done
before but I feel like I would like
it yeah same here I like to do do that
this guy is busted I can't believe we
went from Tech Support to Mr buffering
that is crazy my man loads before he
answers yeah yeah that's a that's a
dream of mine oh my God this is what
failed AI looks like when it's imprinted
into human this is brutal yeah this is
this is that Windows 95 if you had to
pick a food that described your sex life
what food would it be inline
you go first oh she said you go first
you look like you know about
eating that [__]
crazy iest
see they did they add that little noise
okay I'm not crazy i s like nachos or
something like that nachos yeah
nachos n
nachos
my guy out of everything you said
nachos that's actually a class that's
funny nachos that's funny what food
describes
you probably just saying
Char like sexually that's what it is I
think yeah break off a piece and share
me
hey I'mma Be that you cuz I put you to
sleep after it's pretty good
line yeah
okay why is nachos your sex life yeah
cheese sauce I
guess I don't know why you you always
say it always IR me when you say dick
cheesy said cheese sauce and that's
that's exactly what I thought I said
that dick
greasy okay
cool um why be paing help
help she want to hear so bad Buton you
going to say anything I thought it was I
guess not
okay sorry no it's all right I get it
it's all right so nice meeting you too
what is your interests I'm not going to
lie li like I work a lot cuz it's a
startup business so I wanted to go far
what do you do for work so I have candy
fruit business and um started off as a
hobby kind of grew into a business I
also rent out bouncy houses on the side
oh [__] okay I work right now I just
graduated so I'm only working part-time
um I feel like we weren't really like
vibing you
know why didn't they give me no C I'm so
mad right now because we're [__] okay
she went backstage said yeah why they
give me a bunch of
uglies why they give me a bunch of
uglies and [__] tech support guys I
mean I don't need my computer fixed I
get it I get it people that she's driven
so in her head she's like you don't you
just you just got out of school you part
I'm not your mom I'm not going to take
care of you other guy text a poor guy
doesn't want to talk about himself
awkward as [__] G uh Yogi Bear over
there not talking and [__] talking
about cheese sauce is his sex life yeah
like I get I get they didn't do her
justice I get why she mad I get why she
mad love your tattoos F thank you are
you an overthinker absolutely an
overthinker yeah like I just finished
like school and stuff so I've always
been like super introspective and
intellectual I just finished like school
and stuff so I've always been like super
introspective and like intellectual and
like into the Mind Games Girl You Ever
Had mind sex we don't have to take
clothes off yet we can just chill relax
get
set before we get intimate let's have a
good mindful stimulation you know let's
play over a game of Monopoly and discuss
economy capitalism communism all the
isms until I get into your
Schism of the Rapture of your beautiful
rapturous mind reflect to the prism of
your Consciousness consciously making
decisions
I just graduated from University but I
ain't got a job though unless it's
part-time cuz I'm full-time on my grind
of intellectually spreading the good
word
yeah it had to be slam poetry what did
you go to school for mechanical
engineering but I'm like right now I'm
kind of easing off I'm like doing music
are you singer or like a produc singer
oh ter
her you don't have you want to I mean I
feel like I got to about chicken nuggets
for me a chicken
nugget she went from you don't have to
if you don't want to to serenade me with
chicken nuggets too
nervous baby let me get your chicken
nuget
he did that drag
[__] baby let give
you hold on we're going home home baby
let me you that chicken nuget Hey listen
I'd rather do slam po than ever serenate
a girl s yeah absolutely I'll be your
barbecue sauce I'll be your dip oh [__]
it's got really hot in here yeah what
dip oh oh yeah yeah dip dip what dip do
you use so I'm definitely getting
multiple ran I'm going to wait I think
he pressed me first o why' you press me
just how I tell her it was a good vibe
for you know a second but it was not
very as deep as I wanted to get I mean I
don't want to go super deep but we
started talking about chicken nuggets I
was just trying to help you with your
saong good luck thank you I'm Josiah
Dasha Dasha nice to meet you I like you
dressed okay now would would you say
you're a patient man oh or do you have
like atient temper I've never had like a
temper and what's the relationship with
like your mom and your dad God damn okay
there psych major what the [__] that's
really what it is that's what it is hey
hey what's your relationship with your
mom just hit the button like you already
know you want to press it this is weird
do I drink yeah certainly
drink okay yeah do you drink no no I
drink on the weekends oh a lot yeah okay
and what about smoking you smoke yeah I
smoke every day yeah yeah damn oh sorry
damn you went damn my name is Josiah I'm
IET IET nice to meet you are your eyes
green yes for real green sure what's
your interest like what do you like to
do I had a poetry blog for a while
poetry blog
p
say more say less cuz you've already
said everything we started with the word
and now we're at the sentence put the
period on the comma cuz we continuing
everything the end is just the beginning
of the next bar as we hit that paragraph
key on the keyboard now we starting it
properly we got essays on essays you get
what I'm saying essay yeah we Mexican in
this
Hood what no I'm just letting you go
then you already know what I did and I
did yeah did I do did I did I did I did
that's not even a word Hey listen listen
uh I feel like Missy said it best drink
or
scissor you really drink your
scissor you tried to C that one but that
one was not you I I was going to say
something else but your face only talk
like [__] don't do
it s sorry sorry sorry affection talking
about love locked you up like boot up
boot up she be boot up and now we
rapping about chicken nuggets got the
SAU on Deck don't even lie since we've
been working together my my my my raps
get better and better with each year
they really don't they don't they don't
they don't they don't they don't
they don't do
it do it don't do it don't do it don't
do it they don't they don't they
don't okay that was really helpful in
high school cuz I had a hard time
expressing myself okay I like to read
like to go hiking this girl's voice is
so smooth smoother than her skin God Dam
and her skin is smooth as [__] yeah she
definitely got me trying any restaurants
dude I'm in love with this woman on God
I say I love Vietnamese food yeah what
do you put in your F jalapenos the Thai
basil the bean sprouts I put some chili
oil if you're going spicy oh oh yeah you
that thinks goofy men are sexy oh really
are you goofy I'm super goofy okay good
I'm fully expecting this guy to [__]
this up somehow I was very shy growing
up so like I'm very done with that shy
[__] you know like I'm like I would much
rather connect with people that's good
do you find each other attractive yeah
yeah I do I like your tattoo thank you
I'm pretty addicted to get tattoos right
now is it like a pain thing do you like
that uh it doesn't bother me okay why I
you want tattoos no
he's not [__]
up you don't like pain it's more so I
don't know if I'll like it in a couple
years so you like pain
no okay maybe I'm wrong maybe I'm wrong
that happens that's why you didn't
answer the spicy question no I'm just
kidding oh you correlate pain to
spiciness no no I mean I don't know I'm
going to light up one more time okay and
you can choose to walk out of here
together if you don't press me okay here
we go
I'm praying she hits the button just for
the
content you're not going to hit it are
you would
you oh
no
unexpected I'm wrong
sometimes not only did he not [__] it up
he threw it
out that was crazy I didn't see that
coming that was actually awesome he
threw it out he
didn't that's actually a
moment what
happened I don't know
buddy I just feel like we I don't know
there's more people to meet I just want
to meet every as as many people as
possible you got me stuttering over
here
you know love does not come
easy love does not come
easy yeah it was easy sometime Love
Don't Come Easy cuz you [__] it up cuz
you throw it out sometimes love is right
there but you decide to throw it out
does not come easy it's not it does not
come easy because it's difficult it come
not doesn't come easy because sometimes
you throw it out some sometimes it's you
it's not the love it's you it's your
choice anyways hey man listen it maybe
it wasn't attracted her maybe he wasn't
and if that's the case that's okay too
you know you're entitled to feel
whatever you want to feel I didn't see
that coming that was a a nice little
twist ending but hey just because we all
liked her doesn't mean he did so that
was crazy let's know what you guys think
in the comments that was a good ending y